abby's question is it garbage to have a
urinal in your house
that's pretty [ __ ] classy what are
you talking about i think that's just
because i'm trashy but that's [ __ ]
awesome do you live in a buffalo wild
wings
who has that
her parents have it your parents do
you have a regular toilet too right
you're not taking a dump in the urinal
are you
yeah in a minute do you also have one of
those hand dryers
yeah what's the what's the condom
machine like in there
you got a guy working the door mints
cologne anything
i mean how did that happen that's what i
want to know your husband's a contractor
or something like that i would assume
did you hit the lottery what'd you do
and what he had an extra urinal hey
you want it on the job you want to put
it in there
wait also hold on abby did send a
picture as well i don't know if she told
you that she sent a picture in it is way
too close to the sink
[Laughter]
it is like egregiously close to the sink
like there's no way that's up to code
it looks like an irish pub from the
1800s it's just a big block of ice in
there
what do you have like would you change
the urinal and stuff like that too yeah
does a guy come every couple of weeks
smells like the airport change the
advertisements in there too
ayg is coming up
that's awesome though oh it's beautiful
do you like it
i hope you're not using it
he's like well you know things are all
right
you're up there like [ __ ] aerosmith
like
that's why that's all right
family everybody that was great that was
great
that was great
now we get to the real nitty gritty kind
of stuff uh got the pg stuff out of the
way where's jamie uh j at
what's up i see you back there
how are you
okay okay
that didn't sound confident uh i think
the edibles just kicked in
i will tell you in five minutes
who are you here with buddy
very nice very nice
he's also what kind of work do you do
okay that's pretty nice that's pretty
nice
[Laughter]
loots too
what'd you get in your sats
she said assistant not
[Music]
physician the mean one what do you want
you know
hammy is scalpel these are scissors what
are you doing
[Laughter]
okay what's your credit score looking
like
great it's great go all right pretty
good
her question is do you have any family
members buried on the property
[Applause]
wow
he guess when you're saving all that
money on graveyard
i tend to have a good credit score
who is where i have to know
that's actually kind of classy that
means that they're going to own that
a mausoleum is classy
a tomb
but doesn't that mean that they know
they're going to own the property like
in in perpetuity or whatever it is like
for a long time
yeah
i can't believe i pulled it to be honest
with you
and i'll be honest i'm not 100 sure what
it means
but but does that mean that you guys own
the land
it'd be weird if they were written
god damn it we forgot mom [ __ ]
the landlord calls up after you leave
jamie uh
any chance there's two old people in the
back here
the dog pulled them up yeah yeah
there's a hand sticking out of the
flower bed uh
are you guys really into halloween or
what's going on here i don't think we
can give you your deposit back
unfortunately
you can't just bury people
my dad though you gotta go to like the
city and be like someone signed a death
certificate and you ain't thinking no
grave with a shovel you gotta get a
bobcat or something in there
i don't think it is that's what we're
talking about
she's like he did it at nighttime it was
weird i don't know
how did she die she was hitting head
with a shovel yeah
my dad accidentally shot her it was
crazy i don't know
sometimes those things just go off whoa
holy sh that's something else give her a
round of applause
all right all right pittsburgh